everyone knows that el salvador and
president buchelli they've been adopting
bitcoin they love bitcoin they're
literally plugging their entire nation
state into the bitcoin network they've
been purchasing bitcoin they've been
giving bitcoin directly to their
citizens they've built an entire network
of atms they're building bitcoin city
they're even creating bitcoin-backed
bonds to fund a city at the bottom of a
volcano everyone's eyes are on el
salvador but remember they only have
about six and a half million people for
their population and they have about 25
billion dollars in gdp it's a small
nation by almost any way you can
evaluate it but that hasn't stopped
united states politicians from going
ahead and actually creating brand new
legislation that wants to go and look at
the el salvador situation now here's
what the new legislation is actually
asking the state department wants a
report on el salvador's adoption of
bitcoin as legal tender and they want a
plan to mitigate potential risks to the
u.s financial system now this is
absolutely crazy we're talking about a
country with six and a half million
people and 25 billion dollars in gdp do
we really think that they actually could
be a risk to the u.s financial system
that's not maybe we should be more
focused on things here at home now of
course president buchelli he had some
choice words for the united states and
those politicians in a tweet he said
okay boomers you have zero jurisdiction
on a sovereign and independent nation we
are not your colony your backyard or
your front yard stay out of our internal
affairs don't try to control something
you can't control and so if we go ahead
and look what exactly are the
politicians trying to do well here's a
quick overview there's three specific
politicians that are introducing that
legislation to mitigate risks of el
salvador's adoption of bitcoin and if we
actually look at senator jim reisch and
what he's trying to accomplish he
specifically said this new policy has
the potential to weaken u.s sanctions
empowering malign actors like china and
organized criminal organizations
what is going on why are we worried
about what el salvador is doing we have
plenty of problems here at home we've
got seven and a half percent inflation
we've got unemployment that still is
higher than it was pre pandemic we've
got almost 11 million open jobs and we
got a lot of other problems we can be
focused on now of course bitcoin can't
be controlled there is no financial
censorship that is available the united
states as the creator and distributor
the global reserve currency has enjoyed
the position of being able to actually
levy sanctions around countries all over
the globe
bitcoin prevents them from doing that
and what we have to begin to realize is
that there's a lot of countries that
aren't necessarily adversaries of the
united states they just don't want the
looming threat of the u.s cutting their
citizens off from the global financial
system and bitcoin allows because it is
censorship resistant money and that is
exactly what buchelli is describing he's
saying you can't control bitcoin stay
out of our business
why are you coming and messing with our
internal affairs i think these are great
questions and more and more people are
asking why does the united states think
that we are the global police now el
salvador here's the best part they
literally hold about 75 million worth of
bitcoin this is nothing in the grand
scheme of the global financial system
and ultimately what i think is occurring
here is that there's some politicians
who are uneducated who don't quite yet
get what's going on with the younger
generation adopting this decentralized
digital store of value and whether it's
75 million or 75 billion dollars they
simply want to create legislation they
want to create noise they want to remain
relevant they want to be able to go back
puff out their chest and tell their
constituents look i'm looking out for
you
if that was true they wouldn't be
focused on what el salvador was doing
instead we'd be focused right here at
home we have a lot of problems we need
to solve them i'm glad that president
buchelli is giving his citizens bitcoin
maybe the politicians here in the united
states they should be focused on handing
bitcoin directly to the citizens as well
because bitcoin is good for business
it's good for individuals it's good for
corporations it's good for financial
institutions and it's good for nation
states ultimately bitcoin is inevitable
if u.s politicians want to continue to
serve their constituents they're gonna
have to be friendly to bitcoin you're
gonna have to drive adoption of bitcoin
because if not the bitcoiners the crypto
community they're gonna vote them out of
office hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time